jetzt christian lindner für die
fdp-fraktion herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben mit der
internationalen lage ihren beitrag
begonnen
das ist nachvollziehbar und auf der
internationalen bühne wird es mutmaßlich
keine führungspersönlichkeit geben die
mehr als sie bezeugen könnte was sich in
den vergangenen jahren im vergangenen
jahrzehnt verändert hat sie waren in der
volksrepublik china mit einer großen
delegation nahm dort gespräche geführt
sie haben china hier auch zum thema
gemacht
die volksrepublik china ist ein
wichtiger handelspartner deutschlands
und deshalb müssen wir achten auf unsere
eigene wettbewerbsfähigkeit und auf
faire regeln für den handel
die volksrepublik china ist aber auch
ein wettbewerber und das nicht nur in
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht sondern auch
hinsichtlich der grundfragen unseres
zusammenlebens unserer liberalen ordnung
wir erleben dass es dort ein
überwachungssystem gibt die chinesische
führung übt druck auf private
unternehmen deren mitarbeiter von ihrer
meinungsfreiheit gebrauch machen können
was heißt das eigentlich für die in
deutschland tätigen unternehmen und die
dort beschäftigten hier droht uns also
durch die veränderungen in der
volksrepublik china auch unmittelbar
eine einschränkung von freiheiten
insbesondere der meinungsfreiheit in
deutschland davon frau bundeskanzlerin
dürfen wir uns nicht einschüchtern
lassen und deshalb bedauere ich dass sie
bisher die chance versäumt haben den aus
hongkong zu uns gekommen oppositionellen
josch werbung zu empfangen mit dem tisch
wir sind allerdings alle gefordert ist
nicht nur eine aufgabe der politik
sondern beispielsweise eine aufgabe auch
der deutschen wirtschaft klare worte zu
sprechen
der vorstandsvorsitzende der siemens ag
käser ist nie verlegen um ein scharfes
wort in richtung der afd nie verlegen um
kritik beispielsweise an donald trump
sehr habe ich mich aber gewundert dass
herr keser mit blick auf die chinesische
regierung vor zu scharfer kritik gewarnt
hat liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
gute geschäfte in allen ehren für uns
muss aber klar sein wirtschaftlicher
freiheit und gesellschaftliche freiheit
dürfen nie voneinander getrennt werden
die welt die welt ist im wandel frau
merkel sie haben das haben das
angesprochen werden der welt unterwegs
ist erkennt dass der brh exit da muss
das verhältnis zwischen deutschland und
dem vereinigten königreich auch die
laterale auf eine neue basis gestellt
werden wir blick auf die vereinigten
staaten brauchen wir nicht nur dialog
mit den politischen offiziellen sondern
auch in die zivilgesellschaft hinein
wir haben aufstrebende länder wie wie
die asian staaten
ich war einmal leise ja musste erfahren
der letzte deutsche bundesminister der
dort zu gast war der hieß michael glos
davon nachlässigen wir eine
wachstumsregion wie viele referenten wie
viele referenten beschäftigen sich
eigentlich im ministerium von heiko maas
mit der volksrepublik china eine
handvoll eine asien abteilung wurde
gegründet aber nur eine stelle für einen
abteilungsleiter wurde geschaffen
wie viele goethe-institute und
generalkonsulate bekommen wir eigentlich
in der welt um unsere präsenz zu
verstärken
in der internationalen politik frau
bundeskanzlerin in der internationalen
politik jenseits ihrer person in der
internationalen politik boxt deutschland
strukturell unter seiner gewichtsklasse
schon heute es ist nicht verstehe warum
im kommenden bundeshaushalt ausgerechnet
beim auswärtigen amt sogar noch weiter
gekürzt werden soll in zeiten wo wir
nicht weniger diplomatie sind mehr
diplomatie bord
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben gerade
auf den gestrigen abend hingewiesen
unseren gemeinsamen besuch beim bund der
steuerzahler
sie haben dort gesprochen das war auch
aller ehren wert
dann sind sie gegangen und dann gab es
eine podiumsdiskussion und bei der
podiumsdiskussion ging es um
staatsverschuldung war ging es um
steuergerechtigkeit
da ging es um steuerverschwendung da
ging es um die verfassungswidrigkeit
ihres modells den soli abzuschmelzen
deshalb frau bundeskanzlerin habe
bundeskanzlerin es war gut dass sie zum
bund der steuerzahler gegangen sind und
dass sie dort gesprochen haben
meine begeisterung würde heute aber
keine grenzen erkennen wenn sie auch
geblieben wären uns zugehört hätten was
dort gesagt worden
wir haben eine schwarze null im haushalt
die wird vielfach gerühmt und diese
diese schwarze null
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen hat für
uns als freie demokraten zunächst einmal
eine hohe symbolkraft in europa wer bei
uns auch leichtfertig über die rückkehr
der staatsverschuldung spricht der
riskiert dass das andere in europa zum
beispiel in italien als eine einladung
verstehen wie der politik auf punkt zu
machen wer in deutschland über neue
schulden spricht
wird eine rückkehr der
staatsschuldenkrise in europa die
traurige wahrheit ist ja auch dass wir
in deutschland ja ausschließlich auf dem
papier eine schwarze nun haben es wird
ja von den bundesfinanzminister olaf
scholz längst wieder mehr ausgegeben als
er einnahmen erzielt der
haushaltsausgleich der schwarzen null
wird ja nur erreicht indem 9 milliarden
euro aus der rücklage entnommen werden
irgendwann werden die rücklagen
aufgebraucht sein
wir gehen in schwierige wirtschaftliche
zeiten frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben es
angesprochen
da werden sozialausgaben steigen und
steuereinnahmen weiter reduziert sie
haben den boom nicht genutzt um unser
land wettbewerbsfähig zu machen
um dafür zu sorgen dass dauerhaft auch
der staat seine leistungen finanzieren
kann
olaf scholz hat aus der schwarzen null
deshalb in wahrheit eine rote null
gemacht dieser haushalt hält nur noch
für die restlaufzeit der regierung
merkel
und wie ein an cholera wie ein bumerang
werden die in der vergangenheit
getroffenen entscheidungen zur rückkehr
auf diejenigen die in zukunft an
verantwortung tragen werden manche
wollen sogar noch mehr jetzt ist die
rede von einer grünen 0
die partei bündnis 90 die grünen will
diskutieren die schuldenbremse
aufzuweichen hören von der csu
landesgruppe es müsse eine klima anleihe
geben
der bundeswirtschaftsminister äußert
sich ähnlich 50 milliarden euro aus
einer stiftung für klimafragen mit einem
garantiezins von 2 prozent das ist eine
zins subvention auf kosten der
steuerzahler und offensichtlich der
traum eines jeden regierungspolitiker es
nämlich über milliarden verfügen zu
können ohne die parlamentarische
kontrolle des deutschen bundestages dazu
kann und dazu darf es nicht kommen
ja glaubt ja da glaubt doch keiner dran
wir haben schon 2009 von dem damaligen
sozialdemokratischen finanzminister
solches gehört da wurde doch ein
konjunkturpaket 2 beschlossen mit jedoch
damals 16 milliarden euro und die zusage
war dieses konjunkturpaket 2 das wird
selbstverständlich dann später getilgt
und olaf scholz zitiert ja auch oft
meinhardt keynes also dann wenn die
wirtschaft nicht läuft dann müsse man
investieren auch gegen gegebenenfalls
aus defiziten zehn jahre nach der
auflegung des konjunkturpakets 2 durch
die damalige große koalition stellen wir
fest 0 euro davon sind getilgt olaf
scholz spricht oft über kenianische
politik aber er macht sie in der regel
nutzer hälfte die schulden nimmt er gern
in kauf aber die schulden später zu
töten das kommt sozialdemokraten
offenbar nicht in gänze deshalb
verehrter anwesende liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen es gibt nicht nur eine
ökologische verantwortung für kommende
generationen es gibt auch eine
ökonomische verantwortung für
nachkommende generationen ihnen nämlich
solide staatsfinanzen zu hinterlassen
eine aufweichung der schuldenbremse
einmal aufweichung der schuldenbremse
genügt dem ziel nichts sondern ganz im
gegenteil brauchen eigentlich eine
verschärfung der schuldenbremse die
ganzen geschenke die
versicherungsfremden leistungen die aus
den sozialkassen finanziert werden
wie müssen aus steuermitteln dargestellt
werden
deshalb brauchen wir zukünftig eine
schuldenbremse 20
die dafür sorgt dass nicht nur der
staatshaushalt generationengerecht ist
sondern dass auch die
sozialversicherungen den interessen der
kinder und enkel
und wenn wir zukunft schaffen wollen in
der zukunft schaffen
vorher gibt es noch alternativen zu
schulden frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
völlig zu recht von planungs
beschleunigung gesprochen da brauchen
wir dringend mehr
es kann ja nicht sein dass diejenigen
die im bundestag gar nicht schnell genug
erneuerbare energie ausbauen wollen
zugleich vor ort an der spitze der
bürgerinitiativen stehen die
protestieren gegen neue stromtrassen was
nicht zusammen also erster punkt planus
beschleunigen zweiter punkt schwerpunkte
im haushalts- setzen und mal fragen
brauchen wir jede subvention titel
schafft fragen brauchen wir jede ausgabe
ich habe mich gewundert über den cdu csu
fraktionsvorsitzenden ralph brinkhaus am
tag der generaldebatte im deutschen
bundestag über den entwurf eines
bundeshaushaltes sagte der vorsitzende
der regierung tragenden unionsfraktionen
in den zeitungen
also das was da vorgelegt worden ist
eigentlich müsste man doch jeden titel
ansehen wörtlich wir brauchen eine
generalrevision des bundeshaushaltes
wenn sie sagen eine generalrevision des
bundeshaushaltes titel schafft dann ist
doch nichts anderes als ein
misstrauensvotum gegenüber olaf scholz
auf welcher grundlage beraten sicher
denn da wir haben auch vorschläge
wir haben auch vorschläge wir haben auch
vorschläge zum beispiel das
baukindergeld wenn sie davon so sehr
überzeugt werden würden sie das ja auch
auf dauer gewähren
die europäische kommission setzt zweiter
in dieses vorhaben werden dabei auch mit
deutschem steuergeld den bau von
eigenheimen außerhalb deutschlands
finanzieren weil die beschäftigten hier
zeitweilig gearbeitet haben also da
können wir auch streichen
dritter punkt investitionsoffensive aber
nicht auf pump gehen wir doch mal
unternehmerisch daran wie halten wir es
mit den aktien die der staat hält über
die kfw am telekom an post und so weiter
die könnte man privatisieren und die
sorten doch nicht in die klebrige finger
von olaf scholz sondern zielgerichtet
investiert werden in zukunft
infrastruktur
vierter punkt prioritäten
zukunftsaufgaben gibt zb die
digitalisierung in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen mindestens
zwölf milliarden euro für digitales
ergebnis es gibt schlappe 6 milliarden
etwa die hälfte
sie sprechen immer von zukunft durch
bildung wunderbar schaut man sich den
haushalt der bonus bildungsministerin an
stellen wir fest - 70 millionen euro
ausgerechnet bei der zukunftsaufgabe
bildung kürzt diese koalition
sinnvoll wäre es dort mittel zu
verstärken etwa indem es auch eine
exzellenzinitiative für die berufliche
bildung zukünftig gibt also liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was wir
brauchen
das sind nicht neue schulden was wir
brauchen das ist neues denken mein
letzter punkt dazu gebrauchen vertrauen
in die menschen und in private
investitionstätigkeit die unionsfraktion
fordert eine unternehmenssteuerreform
und sie hat recht haben wird denn wir
sind international nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig aber wie ich die
tatsächliche politik
die forderung ist her und
unterstützenswert wie ist die
tatsächliche politik
sie unterstützen das aus dem
solidaritätszuschlag eine strafsteuer
für führungskräfte leistungsträger und
die deutsche wirtschaft gemacht wird
unterstützen sie und gas
und das obwohl sie ja selbst
verfassungsrechtliche bedenken gegenüber
dem modell das sie beschließen wollen
geltend gemacht haben peter altmaier
bundeswirtschaftsminister sogar ein
kabinettsmitglied erklärt öffentlich die
nicht vollständige nur teilweise
abschaffung des solidaritätszuschlages
könnte verfassungswidrig sagen da sind
große haushaltsrisiken mit verbunden uns
die nehmen das alles so hin
ich mache ihnen ein angebot wenn die
unionsfraktion an gesetzentwurf zur
vollständigen abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags 4 1 bringt sie
können sicher sein der stimmen zu und
wenn sie das und wenn sie das wenn sie
das seriöserweise wenn sie das
seriöserweise aufgrund der
rücksichtnahme auf ihren
koalitionspartner spd nicht im bundestag
als gesetz beschließen können dann habe
ich hier als alternative ein milderes
mittel dann klagen sie gegen das gesetz
in karlsruhe mit uns damit die menschen
rechtssicherheit haben und eine
verfassungswidrige strafsteuer nicht auf
dauer im bundesgesetzblatt bleibt das
ist im übrigen ein instrument das ist im
übrigen ein instrument das bei
rechtlicher unsicherheit in der
vergangenheit in den 1990 er jahren
erinnere an gewisse auslandseinsätze
awacs einsätze bereits angewandt worden
ist um rechtssicherheit zu schaffen das
wäre nichts neues
ich muss aber bei der gelegenheit noch
einen satz sagen an dem
bundesfinanzminister und seine partei
ich habe natürlich verständnis für
profilierungs notwendigkeiten und dass
man dinge auch anders sehen kann
natürlich wir sind ja in einer
lebendigen parlamentarischen demokratie
in dem auch unterschiede deutlich
gemacht werden und ich verstehe dass sie
dass die leistungsträger auch schon den
teamleiter beim daimler am band das sie
die zusätzlich belasten wollen dass sie
kein verständnis dafür haben dass der
deutsche mittelstand den internationalen
wettbewerb entlastung braucht das daran
arbeitsplätze hängen das daran
tarifentwicklung hängen dass die
unternehmen erfolgreich sind dass sie
das alles
sehen wollen einverstanden das ist ihr
gutes recht und jeder sucht sich seine
unterstützung in der bevölkerung auf die
adria will aber bestimmte dinge gehen
wirklich über die geschmacksgrenzen
hinaus da gibt es bei der spd also den
wunsch strafsteuer so lieben und das
ganze wird dann bebildert von der
sozialdemokratie in dem an der mensch in
den liegestuhl setzt longdrinks nur
filmt wo das geld auf dem fließband
abgeliefert wird wenn das ihr bild von
leistungs kräften von leistungsträger
und unserem mittelstand ist dann haben
sie sich vollständig von der
lebenswirklichkeit in unserem land
entkoppelt und im übrigen und im übrigen
auch das mal zu lernen
man kann ja auch man kann ja auch jede
verteilungspolitische diskussion führen
einverstanden
da hätte ich auch dinge anzumerken wie
wir zum beispiel ist erleichtert dass
menschen zu vermögen kommen indem wir
nicht bestrafen wenn man wertpapiere
kauft durch die neue aktien steuer könne
nur über oder über die grunderwerbsteuer
können versprechen habe ich auch viele
ideen über über verteilungsfragen zu
sprechen von einer anderen perspektive
als sie aber eins muss man auch sagen
diejenigen die massiv von ihrem privat
erwirtschafteten einkommen an den staat
abgeben
die verdienen am ende auch ein klein
wenig respekt da darf man vielleicht
auch einmal sagen danke
wenn von eurer leistungsfähigkeit
profitieren auch diejenigen die selbst
nicht so viel leistung gegenwärtig
bringen kann und ich komme zu meinem
dritten und der letzten punkt in die
ansprechen will nach frau merkel ist die
klimapolitik
die cdu-bundesvorsitzende hat ja einen
kino konsens vorgeschlagen und wir sind
zur mitwirkung daran bereits für mich
ist noch ein wenig rätselhaft wie das
verfahren sein wird denn die union
selbst wird ja ihre position erst vier
tage bevor das klima kabinett eine
position bezieht festlegen und dann soll
das ganze auch noch gegenstand
überparteilicher gespräche werden also
wir sind gespannt aber wir haben auch
erwartungen
unsere erwartung ist dass es dann bitte
nicht nur um klein klein geht vielleicht
sind wir nicht alle einer meinung aber
ich wage zu sagen
ein anderer mehrwertsteuersatz auf
wurstwaren in deutschland wird das
weltklima nicht retten und auch eine
debatte und auch eine debatte über das
verbot von inlandsflügen in deutschland
wird uns auch nicht sehr helfen
ich glaube dass das ohnehin in wahrheit
die kreativste form ist davon abzulenken
dass die menschen vom flughafen berlin
brandenburg sowieso überhaupt gar nicht
fliegen können
das wollen wir nicht und wir möchten die
klimapolitik auch nicht zu einem
schauplatz von kultur kämpfen machen
muss man ganz klar zu sagen hier
die einen sprechen über messer männer
und das inakzeptabel
aber auf der anderen seite dass man es
pauschal zu mord instrumenten macht
angesichts eines tödlichen unfalls in
berlin das ist am pietätlosigkeit neben
falls nicht zu überbieten
wir wollen also sprechen wir wollen also
sprechen über über wirksame maßnahmen
also wie wäre es beispielsweise alle
öffentlichen gebäude werden mitte des
nächsten jahrzehnts klimaneutral und
zugleich werden die möglichkeiten
geschaffen zukunft infrastruktur beim
digitalen also antennen zu installieren
zweiter punkt energetische
gebäudesanierung der schlafende riese
berg immer wenn wandel des klimawandels
der klimaschutzpolitik logopäde ja
klimaschutzpolitik warum haben wir da
längst nicht eine steuerliche förderung
drittens drittens nicht nur bestrafen
und betreiben wenn jemand co2 ausstößt
wie wär's denn geschaffene möglichkeit
wird co2 speichert bekommt eine prämie
zb durch die aufforstung von wald das
ist das gegenteil
übrigens das ist das gegenteil was die
regierung seit 2005 macht wie viele
hektar wald aus öffentlichen besitz sind
den naturschutzverbänden geschenkt
worden die die jetzt renaturieren also
in wahrheit sich selbst überlassen
rückzugs auto des borkenkäfers und wir
können die natürlichen möglichkeiten der
co2 speicherung durch
forstwirtschaftlich nutzen ändern wir
das doch vierter punkt
ja doch sprechen sie mal mit dem thema
mitarbeitern der kollege hofreiter das
sind die die praxis machen die nicht im
bundestag sitzen sondern im wald stehen
wird viertens stadt verbot von
ölheizungen
damit bringt man die leute doch auf die
palme verbot von ölheizungen leute
decken doch sie müssen jetzt da tausende
euro investieren in ihrem haus statt
verbot von ölheizungen nutzen wir doch
die möglichkeit treibhausgas
freundlichere brennstoffe zu entwickeln
das gilt übrigens auch für die autos
frau merkel ihre regierung hat zu
verantworten dass synthetische
kraftstoffe die es erlauben dass das
ganz normale auto mit verbrennungsmotor
deutsche spitzentechnologie dass das in
deutschland ein auslaufmodell ist weil
nämlich synthetische kraftstoffe auf den
co2 flottenverbrauch in brüssel nicht
angerechnet werden
sie haben eine deutsche
spitzentechnologie dort fort sie haben
eine deutsche spitzentechnologie gemobbt
worden
besser das was sie gesagt haben
marktwirtschaft brauchen wir in der
energie und klimapolitik ist richtig
aber dass sie das ausgerechnet mit eeg
und energiepolitik verbunden haben das
ist wirklich der treppenwitz der
geschichte denn weil wir keine
marktwirtschaftliche energiepolitik
haben wird alles teurer ohne dass wir
tatsächlich co2 einsparen machen wir es
also anders machen wir es also anders
und ich glaube dass ich glaube dass
darin auch eine globale verantwortung
deutschlands liegt manche wollen
klimaschutz machen mit askese verbot
verzicht kein wachstum der
lebensstandard des jahres 1995 so
schlecht war der doch auch nicht kann
man alles wollen gibt es auch
unterstützung dafür
wir werden auf dem weg möglicherweise
auch moral weltmeister werden aber
niemand wird uns auf der welt folgen
die können nämlich nicht auf wohlstand
verzichten oder sie keinen haben
die wollen auch nie
verzichten was gar nicht viel zu
verzichten gibt die wollen nicht einfach
nur bescheiden sein weil sie noch ganz
grundlegende frage ihrer lebenschancen
klären müssen deshalb unser anspruch
kann man ja vorher moral
weltmeisterehren unser anspruch muss
doch sein
deutschland muss wieder durch
marktwirtschaft und erfindergeist
technologie weltmeister werden der nur
als technologie weltmeister werden da
ein vorbild für die welt
christian immer partei und natürlich
auch fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp im
deutschen bundestag